talk to me about tiger woods i love how
opinionated you are
i think the guy psychologically just
doesn't want to win i think the issue
with tiger or his parents
i think his father was a pain in the
neck they did not bring him up right
mistrustful hate the media now they did
a great job of creating a great champion
so you can't i mean that's part of the
deal here too you got to give me i mean
he's the greatest golfer
outside of nicholas he's the greatest
golfer of all time they did a great job
from that standpoint
what's going on with a-rod and j-lo will
they stay together
a-rod needs j-lo more than j-lo needs
a-rod j-lo
she's fine she got a million fans she
can do movies she can do anything she
wants
a-rod can't play baseball anymore he's
not hitting any more home runs
it's over he's not also going to the
hall of fame either you can forget that
it's steroid he's not doing that
so if a rob if era doesn't have jlo you
think he's on espn every
doing sunday night baseball and there's
not a chance in america you think he's
on fox
no so he needs jlo actually more than
jlo needs a-rod
so if i'm a-rod you know what i stay
together with jlo
what is a better movie the godfather or
godfather two
uh i think because of the novelty of it
and the fact it was the first one and
it's a pretty quick conclusion when he's
uh you know christening with his kid
i would say one is better they are both
great
who is going to win the title of
jeopardy hosts
this idea that aaron rodgers is going to
quit football
or whatever he's going to do to be a
game show host aaron don't take yourself
so seriously
all right right play football right
right i mean you're 36 37 years of age
you're a hall of fame quarterback and
you're still great
play football the idea now that aaron
rodgers is going to stop what he's doing
playing football and run and go do
jeopardy
is a little much well let's call it like
we see it no you're lame
where are you at with the sopranos
ending was it a good ending or was it a
bad ending
no it was a bad ending i was a parent
that was a bad guy
thank you i haven't you wanted somebody
to walk in and knock them off they were
having a lunch there in that little
diner that was a bad ending for crown
out loud yes
this is what a great broadcaster does
he's got an answer he doesn't even know
if he's right but he's right
because he says he's right by the way i
have to ask one question chris
is there any chance you will show up
somewhere
having forgotten your pants when you're
doing a broadcast
at home it's possible yeah you know at
home because you know you don't you
don't think of it you just go up you see
a lot of people robin's referring that a
lot of people with the zoom they come
into a room they decide just to wear a
shirt no pants
that's right it lines up on tv
because i want to feel relaxed with you
and i love this great t-shirt
now i would not wear i would not wear
this normally
but i want to be relaxed with you so we
can do a good interview because that's
my main goal
and i'll feel better if i come here
dressed up i feel too stuffy but if they
come here
i'm actually wearing shorts see let me
see let me see your legs